bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
il faut s'attendre selon vous à
l'annoncé d'un troisième confinement ses
premiers ces prochains jours en france
oui ça paraît malheureusement inévitable
on voit toutes les précautions que prend
le gouvernement pour éviter d'utiliser
le mot mais rien ne peut ouvrir ni les
stations de ski ni les restaurants ni
les lieux de culture
tout continue comme avant avec le
couvre-feu avec des courbes qui
soi-disant repartirait à la hausse avec
ce variant angles est un plus dangereux
que ce qu'il n'y paraissait plus
contagieux aussi visiblement
et puis j des voisins européens qui le
confine y compris dans les écoles
donc ça va être compliqué hein pour le
gouvernement français d'ouvrir
d'expliquer qu' on ne va pas faire comme
les autres avec des mesures toujours
aussi incompréhensibles comme par
exemple ces tests pcr pour ceux qui
voudraient venir en france sauf si vous
venez en voiture par exemple ou à cheval
ou à pied ou je ne sais pas comment mais
le test pcr voilà qui ne sera pas
respectée forcément et toujours cette
idée d'avancer pas à pas pour que les
français acceptent l'inacceptable d'être
encore enfermés encore pendant quelques
semaines
alors si c'est un confinement comme le
deuxième confinement qui était plus
l'axé avec les écolos verte etc
c'est peut-être possible est ce utile
toute la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est est ce que ces mesures
de confinement de couvre-feu ont un
impact suffisant sur la lépi grands
virus puisque depuis un an qu'on essaye
à peu près toutes ces mesures là et bien
rien n'y fait le virus est toujours
parmi nous et il se propage alors
peut-être à moindre mesure c'est ce que
nous dirons les autorités mais tout de
même le prix à payer le bilan à payer
économique notamment et sociales et
psychologiques risquent d'être énormes
avant d'en entendre parler ce que les
français ne s'y prépare pas finalement à
ce troisième confinement est ce que le
gouvernement n'a pas préparé les esprits
ces derniers jours et est ce que la
mesure donc pourrait ne pas être plus
facilement acceptée mais c'est toute
l'idée de cette stratégie des petits pas
qui est l'équivalent du nudge en
marketing c'est à dire progressivement
emmener les gens là où on veut un peu
comme un chien de berger qui va à boyer
sur les moutons pour les pousser dans un
coin de dupré c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement sans aboyer plus tôt en
faisant des sourires en expliquant avec
beaucoup de
de d'image powerpoint avec toute cette
stratégie sans doute payé très cher aux
cabinets de conseil comme mckinsey et
berne pour dire allez-y mollo fait que
les français acceptent sinon vous allez
tout droit à une révolte sociale
donc pour que ça passe eh bien on
habitue les français à l'inhabituel on
fait comme si tout cela était normal et
c'est encore une fois une stratégie de
communication pas une stratégie
sanitaire et c'est encore une fois une
stratégie de d'enfermement et pas une
stratégie de mise de moyens sanitaire
sur la table puisque on manque de
vaccins évidemment on ne connaît pas non
plus l'efficacité globale du vaccin une
fois la campagne de vaccination terminée
et que les mesures sanitaires
vous avez vu on passe de 1 m à 2 m sur
minable alors on pas changé deux mètres
c'est mieux à m c'est pas bien ce sera
plus si sa table ce sera sans doute 4
voire deux et puis empêcher les gens de
bouger surtout parce que ce virus c'est
nous qui les portons idées partout et
tant qu'on sera dans des demi mesures ou
dans ces mesures là et on va continuer
évidemment longtemps avec ce virus
puisque il ya deux stratégies vivre avec
ou bien essayer de l'éradiquer ce virus
c'est très compliqué de l'éradiquer pour
cf des mesures absolument liberticide
les français n'en veulent pas c'est le
cas de la chine par exemple enfermer les
gens faire des centres de quarantaine
l'allemagne est en train aussi de suivre
cette route la fermer les frontières
totalement ce que ne veut pas emmanuel
macron et puis empêcher bien sûr les
mouvements on en est loin donc on
continue avec ces mesures qu'on ne
comprend pas qu'ils sont dans le temps
long et qui finalement ont très peu
d'effet par rapport à ce virus qui
continue lui de circuler et qui reste
même si le co vario anglais plus
mortelle ça reste un virus qui tue des
gens mais quand même pas comme le
hezbollah ou thé virus ou là ont tué un
grand pourcentage de population
quelles sont les perspectives
aujourd'hui pour l'exécutif dans sa
lutte contre le virus qui s'éternisait
ce que effectivement quand le comme le
gouvernement le laisse présager ce que
tout repose sur la vaccination selon
vous alors oui clairement aujourd'hui
toute la communication s'est concentrée
autour de la campagne de vaccination ici
elle n'est pas un succès ça va être très
compliqué pour le gouvernement d'en
sortir la tête haute
le problème c'est que cette campagne de
vaccination elle a commencé très
doucement avec toujours ce problème de
pénurie cette fois-ci pénurie des deux
11 et on le voit bien le gouvernement a
déjà en train de préparer
l'échec de cette campagne de vaccination
avec les dernières déclarations
d'olivier veyrat qui passe le matin
d'annoncer peut-être 15 millions de
vaccinés avant l'été et sans doute pas
tout le monde y compris des personnels
soignants et les clips et des personnes
à comorbidités et le soir au jt d'une
grande chaîne annoncé 70 millions de
français c'est à dire plus que la
population française vaccinée à la fin
de l'été et pourtant olivier ans est un
des trois ministres qui a le droit de
prendre la parole c'est vous dire
comment ça patauge dans la communication
officielle et ce principe de dire que
les doses n'arrivent pas assez
olivier véran dit que la stratégie du
gouvernement est parfaite si les doses
sont livrés si le vaccin est tous les
vaccins sont efficaces les candidats
vaccins qui ne sont pas encore là ça
fait beaucoup de si
pour que ça fonctionne donc on se
prépare déjà à ce que la stratégie
vaccinale soit un échec ou du moins pas
eu la réussite formidable que tout le
monde attende notamment les marchés
financiers parce que le vaccin est là
pour ça et puis vous avez l'attitude des
laboratoires totalement odieuse comme
pfizer qui disent finalement puisque
l'autorité de santé européennes l'
agence du médicament européen a décidé
qu'il y avait six doses dans les petits
flacons qui initialement était prévu
pour cinq doses eh bien on va vous en
livrer - voilà puisque c'est écrit dans
le contrat on n'est pas là pour vous
aider on est là pour faire de l'argent
et oui les big pharma sont là pour faire
de l'argent ont fait semblant de le
découvrir
mais rappelons nous à l'époque lorsque
les rapports avaient été publiées pour
parler du 95 % d'efficacité du vaccin
freezer le jour même le patron de pfizer
avait vendu ses actions pour plus de 5
millions d'euros
comme beaucoup de hauts cadres de la
compagnie c'était dans un accord de
contrat à partir du moment où il est
arrivé à cette annonce du 95 % il avait
le droit de vendre leurs actions
donc les big pharma elles sont pas là
forcément pour aider les gouvernements
elles sont là pour que les gouvernements
les paye et d'ailleurs on attend que les
contrats soient rendus publics
un seul contrat jusqu'à présent a été
rendu public par la commission
européenne comptera bien sûr signé au
niveau européen c'était celui avec curve
ac les autres reste totalement interdite
au public interdit y compris aux députés
européens
merci beaucoup pour votre regard alexis
à poulies